can you is there a nice way to
to delineate draw a line between marxism
and socialism or or
if if marxism is kind of a part of
socialism
can you speak to like
maybe try to define once again what
marxism is
and what socialism is right
marxism is a
systematic
analysis
heavily focused on economics
and as i said earlier
devoted to
mostly
a critique
of capitalism
and that's its strength
how it does that how it poses the
questions how it analyzes the way my
capitalism works
that is really the forte of the marxist
tradition
socialism is a bigger broader tent
within which marxism
uh figures it's there
so that people who aren't marxists are
nonetheless aware of marxism
like it more or less study it more or
less
uh but it's a broader notion
that i like to use this sentence to
describe
it's a broad idea that we can do better
than than capitalism that really
there are all kinds of
things about capitalism
that are not what we as modern citizens
of the world
uh think are adequate that we are in a
tradition
that goes back to all the people who
thought they could do better than
slavery and all the people who thought
they could do better than feudalism
uh we've made progress feudalism was a
progress over slavery
capitalism was a progress over both of
them and progress hasn't stopped and we
are the people who
in a variety of ways
want
the progress
to go further further and are not held
back
by believing that capitalism is somehow
the best beyond which we cannot go or
even think we find that to be
in the worst sense of the word a
reactionary way of thinking and we're
that large community many of us are not
interested in economics all that much we
don't think that's
the focal area we are socialists for
example because we want to do something
to deal with climate change to
we think the world is about to kill
itself um uh physically and we want to
take steps with other people to stop
that to fix that etc etc
so that's for me
uh a kind of difference
it's a little difficult to say because
there's no other figure
like marx
that has an equal
impact an equal place within the broad
socialist tradition
and the only tradition that comes close
might be
the anarchist tradition but that's very
specialized and that's a whole nother
kind of conversation and whatever you
say the influence of the great anarchist
thinkers uh krapotkin bakunin
um sorel and fran and others
still doesn't amount to the impact that
marx and marxism have had so far that
could change but i mean up to this point
um that's the
um
i think that's a way of understanding
the relationship yeah that's an
interesting that the some of the ideas
within
anarchism and of course it's a one of
the more varied
um disciplines right because there's
such
maybe by definition such variety in
their thinkers but they kind of stand
for a
dismantling of a power center
and that
if not equates tends to rhyme with some
of the ideas of socialism absolutely so
where you have the
you know there's a whole train of
thought in socialist ideas and in
marxist ideas
that uses the phrase quote the withering
away of the state
that's a quotation from lenin
uh people should understand that's a
quotation from lenin
and it was made by lenin positive in
other words lenin was saying that's a
good thing that's something we stand for
we want to create the conditions under
which there is a because you remember
the the
communists or whatever they won't call
that at first in russia before the
revolution they were just socialists
they were hunted down and persecuted by
the government left and right they had
no love for the government the
government was their literal everyday
enemy
and
being critical of government
didn't just mean this particular
government but of the whole
being a marxist you always ask the
questions of the social constitution of
whatever it is you're struggling against
so there was this interest why is the
state so important especially because if
you understand
feudalism particularly early feudalism
it didn't have powerful states
one of lenin's greatest books is called
the economic history of russia and he
goes back centuries it's a huge book
three or four inches thick
and i'm one of the few people who've
read it
and
he's very good about the absence
of a strong central government in many
parts of feud including inside russia
but also in other parts of europe the
development of a powerful central state
comes towards the end of feudalism as it
is desperate to hold on which ought to
be suggestive that maybe the turn to
powerful governments here in the united
states or in europe
is maybe also because this system is
exhausted and can't go on and has to
marshal every last bit of power it can
not to be
lost in history it would be interesting
to see what the soviet union would look
like if lenin never died right
a lot of people have asked that question
over the years other people
there is stalin
sliding in in the middle of the night
erasing the withering away of the state
part yes exactly
you